petit gars me nourris de la petite
enfance initiaux
mapanas maeva si massa qui ait un fils
aussi
[Musique]
ils sont d anciens salariés de toyota
lors de leur embauche il ya des années
on leur avait promis un emploi à vie les
uns après les autres ils ont tout perdu
leur travail leur statut social leur
fierté
[Musique]
non
frappée par la crise et le rappel de
véhicules défaillant toyota et ses
fournisseurs ont licencié des milliers
d'employés en quelques mois au japon
c'est tout un monde qui vacille
[Musique]
toyota était depuis un demi siècle le
symbole de la réussite économique du
pays
c'était une multinationale modèle vénéré
pour l'excellence la qualité et la
robustesse de ses voitures
[Musique]
dans la ville usine de toyota city à 3h
de tokyo la chute est brutale
[Applaudissements]
ici toyota est partout cette cuisine
sans compter ses fournisseurs et quatre
cent mille habitants vivent travaillent
et pense toyoda
tous ont été touchés par la crise pour
la première fois de leur vie
certains questionne ouvertement le
système toyota
[Musique]
comme beaucoup d'ouvriers de toyota city
la famille morimoto vit dans un pavillon
acheté grâce à un crédit alloué par le
fabricant de voitures
je me suis dit ok morimoto est
contremaître chez toyota
sa femme s'occupe de leur fils et attend
un deuxième enfant
[Musique]
les morimoto ressemble à la famille
idéale que toyota montre en exemple dans
le monde entier
[Musique]
et roulant toyota lisent des livres sur
toyota font du sport sur les terrains de
la firme et envoient leurs fils à la
crèche toyota voilà dix ans que
shigeyuki progresse dans sa carrière
travail de jour ou de nuit se plie aux
besoins de l'entreprise
il a des primes et des avantages
garantis actuellement je suis dans une
situation difficile car je suppose
sandwich entre les ouvriers que je
surveille et mes supérieurs qui me met
la pression
malgré le stress je fais de mon mieux
pour progresser dans la hiérarchie mais
c'est vrai que la pression augmente avec
la responsabilité et moi je veux gravir
les échelons tant que parent était
d'ailleurs sur la promotion
mon mari travaille tellement que j'ai
parfois l'impression d'être une mère
célibataire youn qu est né dans une
ville voisine depuis qu'elle vit la
toyota city elle a parfois le sentiment
d'étouffer je ne voulais pas venir vivre
ici
la plupart des salariés de toyota ne
savent même pas à quoi ressemble le
monde extérieur qui vivent dans la vie
où tout tourne autour de toyota
même les horaires d'ouverture des
magasins colosse des usines et c'est
plutôt un étrange pays qu'une simple
ville
depuis la crise de 2008
un tiers des salariés de toyota city a
perdu son emploi au bureau du chômage
les employés non qualifiés ont été les
premiers à pointer c'est chez les sous
traitants que la précarité et le chômage
sévit ce le plus aujourd'hui il n'y a
plus qu'un poste pour quatre personnes
et les latino américains qui ont les
étoiles époux précaire en bas la
hiérarchie ont été les premiers à perdre
leur travail
[Musique]
mon nom et freddy novateur j'ai 45 ans
et j'ai perdu mon emploi
comme des centaines de personnes
[Musique]
freddy est née au pérou de parents
japonais mécanicien de formation il a
été recruté par toyota il y avait un
temps pour travailler sur les chaînes de
montage
[Musique]
je suis arrivé je ne parlais pas un mot
de japonais
mais dès le lendemain j'ai commencé à
travailler tu travailles était due en
intensif par exemple pour aller aux
toilettes je devais demander la
permission et faire en sorte que
quelqu'un ne remplacera la chaîne de
montage il peut jamais arrêté de
travailler
[Musique]
la pression se retrouve à tous les
niveaux dans les bureaux les employés
sans stresser à l'usiné chef de ligne
les ouvriers sont stressées elles
devront fabriquer un bon produit le plus
vite possible et avec de moins en moins
de salariés
pour certains c'est pas supportable ils
partent ou tombent malades
d'anciens collègues sont devenus fous ou
en attraper des maladies comme le cancer
à cause des produits toxiques
on peut dire que c'est injuste mais
c'est comme partout toyota a exporté ses
méthodes dans le monde entier
[Musique]
freddy a tenu bon ils pensaient trouver
un emploi stable
puis retournez ensuite au pérou pour sa
retraite il vit aujourd'hui sur ses
dernières économies dans un hlm
il ne m'est plus chauffage l'hiver et a
coûté son abonnement de portable vous
avez remarqué qu'il n'y a personne qui
marche dans les rues avec la crise en
2008 même les voitures ont disparu
le bureau du chômage vous êtes allée est
plein beaucoup de commerces sont fermés
surtout ceux tenus par des brésiliens et
des péruviens
freddy regarde avec effroi le sort des
milliers de latinos licenciés ils
s'entassent aujourd'hui à plusieurs
familles dans deux minutes que les
appartements les plus désespérés ont
accepté l'aide au retour du gouvernement
et non plus le droit de revenir au japon
pendant cinq ans freddy lui est prête à
tout pour rester malgré ces conditions
de travail difficiles les heures sup les
services de nuit les gestes répétitifs
l'obligation d'écrire des rapports pour
améliorer les rendements les critiques
envers toyota sont rares le fabricant
exerce une pression psychologique sur
ses salariés
toyota city est une ville fermée coupé
du monde extérieur
les usines sont surveillés en permanence
par des gardiens et des caméras un jeûne
cadres employés au siège accepte de nous
rencontrer
il est stressé à l'idée d'être découvert
il nous fait visiter les dortoirs des
salariés de toyota
comme ses collègues il est logé dans une
chambre minuscule
[Musique]
son vieux et ultra basique un peu comme
si on était à l'armée toyota nous
fournit que le strict minimum pour vivre
ces accords peut-être plus de valeur aux
machines qu aux hommes les ouvriers ont
droit à un vrai lavage de cerveau toyota
contre notre vie quotidienne qu'on nous
explique comment nous conduire dans la
vie comment faire du sport
on me traite comme des enfants les en
dépend tellement de toyota que personne
nous en dire du mal
diplômé d'une grande université
japonaise ce jeune ingénieur a été
attirée par le prestige de toyota est le
bon salaire qu'on lui proposait
[Musique]
aujourd'hui il ne supporte plus
l'endoctrinement
il est temps le retour de la croissance
pour chercher un autre emploi tenir tête
au géant
il y a quelques années le combat était
perdu d'avancé le système était clos et
réputé le plus performant au monde
le syndicat maison travaille main dans
la main avec la direction
avec la crise une brèche s'est ouverte
tadao akatsuki ouvriers aux atelier de
pressage des voitures a créé le premier
syndicat indépendant de l'entreprise le
hall tête à liboi onion ducrocq milite
pour de meilleures conditions de travail
une dizaine de personnes seulement se
sont risqués y adhérer mais pour tadao
aucun souci c'est une petite victoire
je veux que toyota considère ses
salariés comme des hommes et pas comme
des robots une blonde on sondheim
il ya quelques années un collègue est
venu me dire qu'il ne supportait plus
les conditions de travail
j'en ai parlé au syndicat officiel ils
n'ont pas levé le petit doigt ce qui
quelques jours plus tard il s'est pendu
pour moi toyota c'est comme la corée du
nord un pays sans liberté ni démocratie
la compagnie menace de licenciement ceux
qui sympathisent avec moi ils ont même
interdit aux autres salariés d' assister
à mon mariage parce que quelqu'un je
suis interne
mais quand on gagne on a toujours de
mars dernier à doha qat sue qui n'a pas
réussi à convaincre ses collègues de
toyota city de le suivre
il rejoint seuls les militants d'autres
grandes entreprises japonaises
certains travaillent chez mitsubishi
d'autres chez honda nous sont
fonctionnaires tous ressentent le déclin
du japon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dans leur slogan is it toyota pour eux
l'entreprise incarne le capitalisme
nippon celui qui promettait de les
protéger et qui aujourd'hui les laisse
tomber
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]